[Music] citizens of the reject Nation you read
the title of this video correctly I have not
seen Willie Wonka in the Chocolate Factory
mentioned that in our Wonka trailer reaction
I did with John and Koy you see every single
month I put together a giant list of movies
I send it out to all the hosts and I find out who
has not seen what so I can do the proper pairings
and blah blah blah blah blah and I am the only
one on the channel who has not seen this classic
so you're getting a Greg solo today with that in
mind ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead leave
a like on this video also subscribe and click
the notification Bell to get notified when we
got something that pops up in your notification
fee that pequs your interest thank you to prepper
for helping us edit down these highlights also
massive thank you to all who have joined our
patreon for the month of December just this entire
year it's been our most successful year thus far
over there you can get the full length Gratch
and watchong it's where you sync up with your
own copy of Willy Wonka on the Chocolate Factory
but John and I also cover several things over
there exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs including the Timothy shalom's Wonka
movie finally coming out fig now is the perfect
time to finally cover this cuz of algorithm
stuff I'm already in the mood for chocolate
now I know this tune I've heard this tune I think
I like kind of know the Oompa Loompa song as well
God I better chocolatey mood already comment
below what is your favorite chocolate I love
me some Reese's Pieces Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
let me be clear Reese's Peanut Butter [Applause]
Cup I appreciate the production design and
making sure every kid was wearing just vibrant
colors they look so happy to be children
listen WKA has got a new one today a new
one scum bar scrum bium bar scrum TR lescent
how does he do it boy do you ask a fish how
it swims no or a bird how it flies no you do
not they do it because they were born to do
it just like Willie Wonker was born to be a
Candyman who can oh we're in a song already
spr inate andac a candy man a the candy man
cand I don't think I've heard this song a
rain like how back then they would trust this
man with a bunch of children Willy Wonka makes
everything he FES satisfying and delicious
what a way to build a Willy Wonka right
away that's some great editing right
there very well composed so [Music] far
taste fickle grubbers what are the names of these
[Music] candies that's Charlie why
wasn't he bonding with the rest of
the children it's payday Mr JC you're
right where's my money there you are
thanks I know we're only a couple minutes in
but this movie is already conveying
such a sense of optimism I want to
say feels a lot more for
boing than I was expecting it
to that's a really cool shot did they build some
[__] that looks great up the Airy Mountain down
the rushing Glen dare not go a hunting for fear
of little men fear of little men you see it's
rude nobody ever goes in nobody ever comes [Music]
out F of is night blades jangling around Charlie's
late he works too hard for a little boy he should
have some time to play not you train him now wow
what an uncomfortable sleeping situation what the
hell is going on here is this your supper Grandpa
I'm fed up with cabbage water it's not enough
Charlie wee Charlie you watch that foul language
how about this Charlie where'd you get that it's
my first payday good for you Charlie we'll have
a real banquet a he used his first payday to give
them bread from now on I'm going to pay for your
tobacco why won't my nephew do that for me not
since the tragic day that Willy Wonka locked it
why do you lock it because all the other chocolate
makers in the world were sending in spies to steal
Mr Wonka's secret recipes especially slugworth oh
that slugworth he was the worst Mr woner shouted I
shall be ruined Clos the factory and that's just
what he did with the Candyman song it makes him
seem like oh so pleasant and then this side of him
makes him sound scary three years later the most
amazing thing happened the factory started working
again and more delicious candies were coming out
than ever before you found Hope but the gate
stayed locked someone must be helping Mr Wonka
work the factory thousands must be helping him but
who children from Cambodia Charlie Bucket yes Mr
Turk I shall need an assistant come and give
me a hand foreshadowing what do you think it
makes I don't know sir course you don't know you
don't know because only I know if you knew and I
didn't know then you'd be teaching me instead
of me teaching you what a sassy little teacher
and I'll take my own special mixture are you
ready good lad po this is very big walls get El
going on out there is this going to come back in
later in the movie what's happening Willy Walkers
opening his Factory he's going to let people in
ooh giving truckloads of chocolate away class
dismissed no no it's only for five people class
UND dismissed five golden tickets and the people
who find them will win the big prize where's
he hidden the tickets inside five Walker bars
you got to buy Wonka bar to find them this does
some surprisingly impressive World building even
as an audience m going yeah i' be trying to like
rack up as many Wonka Bars as possible right now
and to the five people who find them will come
the most fabulous prize one could wish for a
lifetime supply of chocolate o they're all crazy a
genius he'll sell a million bars greatest form of
capitalism Wonka Bars are beginning to disappear
from candy store shelves at a rate to Boggle the
Mind truly it is incredible the way that wonam
Mania has descended upon the globe it's it's cut
this like weird dual layer of of Wonder and semi
thre threatening at the same time dreams doctor
and I still can't stop myself from believing them
to believe in one's dreams is a manifestation of
insanity and the sooner you accept this the
sooner you'll get well well color me insane
doctor but I dreamed the Archangel appeared and
whispered into my ear and told me where to find
a golden Wonka ticket and what exactly did he say
he wants to know I'm a you said just shut up PO
and tell me where the ticket is the first golden
ticket was found in the small town of delheim
Germany damn Germans today right here in dlim the
unexpected discovery of the first Wonka golden
ticket man there's some great Rhythm to this son
of our most prominent Park butcher austo Glo the
fame of Western Germany an example for the whole
world yes congratulations you're hard worker feel
sorry for Wonka it's going to cost an unfortunate
fetch Mr would you mind say [Laughter] gold ticket
eating is his hob you know we he wouldn't do it
unless the hell is going on here some scary German
scientist happy birthday here you are Charlie
terrific we each knitted a bit Grandma Georgina
Grandma Josephine and me and here's a little gift
from Grandpa George and me so they can never get
out of that bed must smell so bad in there open
it Charlie let's see that golden ticket it's not
fair to raise his hopes never mind go on open it
Charlie I want to see that gold stop it I'm going
to buy so many lottery tickets after I'm done
filming I got it where where let's see old you
didn't I you thought I really had it what was the
point of that what was your intention young man I
want you to be the first to find a golden ticket
Daddy I know Angel we're doing the best we can oh
my goodness all right where is it why haven't
they found it barus someone comment below the
fact of how much money they spent on Chocolat
and rappers they're jealous of me sweetheart I
can't push them no harder 19,000 bars an hour
they're shelling 760,000 have' done so far oh
my God you're going to be very unpopular around
here Henry if you don't deliver soon I hate to see
her unhappy I won't talk you ever again you're
a rotten mean [Music] [Laughter] father what
a little BR I got it I got it I would have
just kept it for myself I found the golden
ticket wait he was the one with the the German
boy just had a total Ryan George with there he
was the one with the German boy whichever of
the five continents we are on the great search
for Wonka Bars continues look at that person in
the background watching we're beginning to see
signs of anxiety every hour on the hour new
shipments are being sent to different points
around the globe this mve is like a scorsi
movie Miss Violet borgard finder of Wonka's
golden ticket number three parents Mr borgard
a prominent local politician friend Sam borgard
here Square Deal s to you with here it is golden
ticket number three and it's all M tell us how
it happened Violet this poor Charlie kid cuz I
laid off the gum and switch to candy bars instead
now of course I'm right back on gum chew it all
day except at meal times when I stick it behind
my ear call it mother wish a rotten children
now this piece of gum here is one that I've
been chewing on for 3 months solid and that's
a world record is what is the purpose of this
child he's the guy with a German boy how does
he get to all these children just sneaks up on
them right in their ear I wanted to tell you
something they found a third ticket today did
they no Mrs bugget just doesn't even believe that
it's possible POS there only two tickets left you
know pretty soon just one I wonder who the lucky
ones will be well in case you're wondering if
it'll be me it won't be just in case you're
wondering you can count me out no don't give
me that attitude Charlie there are 100 billion
people in this world and only five of them will
find golden tickets and after this contest is
over you'll be no different from the billions
of others who didn't find one wow you are not a
very empowering mom One day things will change
when when will they change for things to change
you have to change it's better to be prepared for
an opportunity and not have one happen than
to have an opportunity and not be [Music]
prepared oh okay she's just protecting
himile these poor people I
don't mean just financially
[Music] poor oh what a great
[Music] shot oh whoa they pulled out from the
shadow like that this kid has a lot going on
behind his eyes glad you're you I keep saying
kid but he's definitely older than me now if he's
still around I don't know lucky winner number four
now the name soon to be heard around the universe
is Mr Mike TV hey Mike do you think we might shut
that thing off no are you crazy he doesn't even
give a [__] about this new why are all these
children so snotty you like the killings huh what
do you think life's all about Mike would you tell
us wait till I get a real one cold 45 oh jeez pop
won't let me have one yet will you pop not till
you're 12 son not till you're 12 who is this
man they keep letting into people's children they
just let let them around children they got to stop
it Grandpa that money was for
tobacco I told you Charlie I've
given it up a these two which end
shall I open first that end just a
tiny bit like this this kid who is now
a senior citizen is so adorable here
goes I bet those golden tickets make the
chocolate taste [Music] terrible I love
him so much they kidnapped my husband 12
hours ago I'll give them anything anything
they want the hell is this plotline go
ahead we're listening what did they ask
for they watch your case of Wonka bars
it's your husband's life or your case
of wab bars how long will that get me to
think it [Laughter] over this is so well
[Laughter] done that was so funny the fifth and
last colon ticket has just been found right here
in Paraguay Alberto moleta the multi-millionaire
owner of caming casinos for South America damn 1%
R little boy's got to have something in this
world to hope for what's he got to hope for
now who's going to tell him let's not wake him
he'll find out soon enough a poor kid I mean I
know what the plot of what's going to happen
but man the immediate moment you really feel
[Music] it I have no idea what he just picked
up is that some kind of currency I'd like a bar
of chocolate please a slug Sizzler Wonka scrum
didly ous whichever's the biggest try a Wonka
scrum didly ous now that all the tickets
have been found I don't have to hide them
anymore he's such a sweet kid I just feel so
bad for him you'll get a stomach ache if you
swallow it like that bye bye now like that just
like the sadness and hopefulness I just feel it
he's a good act this old man now I think I'll
buy just one more why not try a regular wabal
this time that Gambler from Paraguay made
up a phony ticket that means there's one
golden ticket still floating around somewhere
seriously who is this kid I have no idea who he
[Music]
is man the direction on this the
emphasis on the chocolate bar
hey you've got it you've got the last golden
ticket the kids found the last ticket and then
that guy with the scar shows up it's a whisper
something into his ear come on hold on to the
ticket run for it Charlie run straight
home and don't stop till you get there
aw yo this is some touching ass [__] right now
and I knew this was going to happen
too that's when you know something's freaking
effective who are you may I introduce myself
please ask slugworth president of slugworth
chocolates Incorporated uh he's a spy Mr Wonka is
at this moment working on a fantastic invention
uh-huh the Everlasting Gobstopper e that sounds
gross so all I want you to do is to get hold of
just one Everlasting gobs and bring it to me so
that I can find the secret formula Christopher
Lloyd from who frame Roger Rabbit your reward will
be 10,000 of these think it over with you a new
house for your family he's got morals Charlie
would never I Don't Know Jack about that plot
it's prime example of solid execution even if if
you you know that like yeah I know he supposed to
get the ticket and go to the factory but damn does
it work the last one was a fake it on the papers
I found some money in the street and I bought a
Wonka bar a ticket was in it present this ticket
at the factory gates at 10:00 in the morning
of the first day of October you may bring with
you one member of your own family but no one else
bring one of the grandpa who do wasn't talking say
I can take somebody with me I wish you could go
this movie is going to break me I can feel it oh
man Charlie I did not expect it to be so
touching that's good Charlie
he's going to float like the
Exorcist damn he's doing it are you okay I'm fine
Charlie these other two not talk look
at me he's standing kick Charlie in
the head I never thought my life
could be oh they know when to CU
these musical numbers man so well
so well calculated suddenly I begin
see not going to lie guys St this movie
might be a bit of a chore but I am loving
it so much I never had a chance to shineing
oh he's going around and [Music] around what
a catchy ass song I never thought i' see
the day when I would face the world as
just like boisterous
Wonder but it can be done we haven't even
got a willly Wonka yet I never dreed that
I would climb over the moon in nextasy
but nevertheless it's there that I'm
shortly about to be a great song The Gold
I I don't have I heard this song before I
must have at some point in my life but it
can be never dreed that oh wow he's really
[Music] moving okay now it's going to the
point where you're mocking everyone else on the
bed I really had this like preconceived belief
that I would be sitting here going all right
let's just wait till willly Wonka shows
up and then maybe it'll be become really
fun but we're like 40 minutes in and I'm
still like I'm really enjoying that hell
out of it hiel sweetie I've still got it
now is this God your job must hurt so bad
look at this chocolate man has a scar I want
to go in first before anybody else anything
you say sweetheart save some for later yo
kid you need to get some blood work done
[Music]
wow the build maybe this isn't a good
idea that I'm watching this before the
Timothy shallow one just going to
compare it the whole [Applause]
time oh he's got a [Applause]
limp I thought it was just like a stylistic
choice like a Monopoly man or something
do Monopoly man eat a cane for walking
purposes well clearly all the chocolate
has affected the circulation in
his feet due to the diabetes he
developed great beat what oh hey he didn't need
the Kate after all is a trickster I'm so glad you
could come this is going to be such an exciting
day I hope you enjoy it I think you will [Music]
he got so much there a natural mystery about him
AUST Aus my dear boy how good to see you and in
such fine shape yeah I'm Mike TV well you're
dead wonderful to meet you Mike and Miss Stevie
how do you do what an adorable little boy you
have thank you just over there that's speed on
him I'm so happy for you and who's this gentleman
my grandfather Grandpa Joe delighted to meet you
sir overjoyed and raptured and transed are we
ready yes solid vacular hats coats gashes over
here but hurry please we have so much time and so
little to see wait a minute strike that reverse
it thank [Laughter] you little surprises around
every corner but nothing dangerous and as soon
as you're outer vestments are in hand we'll
begin oh that's fun where coming from floods
fire Frost of fery what I got keep up with
this sign anything for this tour I can't see
what it says in the bar I don't sign anything
without my lawyer my Brer don't sign anything
either then she don't go in I'm Sorry rules
of the house I want to go in don't you dare
stop me just s it you're always making things
difficult nicely handled Bara she's a girl who
knows where she's going I like how he's like
auring but you don't know if you could trust
him there is no other door there's no way
out God most of you are very unlikable ah
here we are don't be a darn fool Wonka
that's the way we came in it is he is a
magician what is this W some kind of fun house
why having fun i' had how clever hey the room is
smaller no it's not he's getting bigger where's
the chocolate I doubt if there is any what is
the point of building a factory like this and
some of my realities become dreams and almost
everything you'll see is eatable edible me I'm
starving now don't get over excited don't lose
your head Augustus we wouldn't want anyone to lose
that yet he's such a great listener like the way
he responds to everyone one hold your breath make
a wish count to three come and you'll I know this
song it's the H song into your [Music]
[Laughter] imagination what a way to play
multifaceted if you want to view Paradise
simply look around and VI are the stairs
edible hurry up Violet this way Grandpa
you enjoy that chocolate eat everything
can you eat the ground no in my luck I
would eat the thing that is not actually
edible oh oh my God what is this place
[Music] That Tune there's something that feels
like questionably malevolent about [Music] it
you be free who are you Wonka it's Industrial
Waste that you've ruined your Watershed Wonka
it's polluted is chocolate that's chocolate
that's chocolate two very different responses
10,000 Gall an hour and look at my waterfall
that's the most important thing it's mixing
my chocolate it's actually churning my chocolate
uh-huh Grandpa look over there across the river
they're little men the the OA loomas are OA
loomas problematic now must be creaming and
sugaring time well they can't be real people well
of course they're real people can't be real people
from LPA land LPA land there's no such place Mr
Wonka I am a teacher geography oh well then you
know all about it and what a terrible country it
is and the poor little Oompa loas were so small
and helpless they would get gobbled up right
and left he's so sincere in his delivery man
he's getting such a great listener hey Daddy
I want an ump lumper I'll get you one before
the day's out I want an LP lumper now oh my God
look at Augustus don't worry he can't drink it
all don't do that you're contaminating my entire
River please I beg you Augustine just stand there
do something help Police Murder it looks like
he's droning dive in save him oh it's too late so
dismissive there's his cat going up the pipe call
a plumber stuck in the pipe there isn't he Wonker
he's blocking all the chocolate what happens now
or the pressure will get him out it's all part of
the plan he's done he'll be made into marshmallows
in 5 seconds impossible my dear lady that's absurd
because that pipe doesn't go to the marshmallow
room it goes to the fudge room take Mrs gloop
straight to the fudge room but look sharp or her
little boy liel to get poured into the boiler
goodbye Mrs gloop one down I've got a puzzle for
these are the rest of the lyrics oh my [Music]
God oh my God it's a music
video oh
all I know is OA looma D Doo so
he rescued the Oompa Loompas but
turned them into his own workers but are
they happier what's the deal with the
oompas All Aboard everybody uh ladies
first and that means Vera if she's a
lady I'm a vermicious knit vermicious
kit I love that phrasing percious kit
what a fun little ride what a great set hi
where are we going I don't know but I don't
like look that tunnel up there hey Wonka I
went off I [Music] don't terminal velocity
have we in know what what the hell is going
on hang on darling close your eyes and hang
on oh this is this is creepy as hell what the hell
is going on tell that little guy to turn
us around walk out now I am going to be
sick couldn't is this just revealing
internally what they're experiencing
this is like a drug trip is a hurricane of
blowing not a speck of light is showing so
the danger must be growing damn some good slam
poetry and there's certainly not showing any
signs that they are slowing I believe this
guy could kill them stop D this should go
far enough quite right sir stop theat we're
there they're inventing room no messing about
no touching no tasting no telling and
whoever doesn't obey the rules gets in
trouble I just get the the impression this
movie was a production nightmare but damn how
cool would it be to walk on this set this is
the most secret machine in my entire Factory
this is the one that's really going to sizzle old
slugworth what's it do uh-oh would you like to see
yeah feel like I've seen that still before but
what's it do can't you see it makes Everlasting
Gob Stoppers that's the thing you can suck
them and suck them and suck them and they'll
never get any smaller how do you make I'm a
trifle deaf in this ear speak a little louder
next time the sarcasm water is so well done
and never show them to another living Soul As
Long as You All Shall Live agreed agreed
agreed fingers cross and one for you and
one for you what about Charlie and one for
Charlie what happens if you take it out of
your mouth how do you preserve it she's
my revolutionary non-pollution mechanical
Wonder whoa they really build this
stuff this little piece of gum is
a three course dinner I wouldn't do
that I really wouldn't so long as it's
gum damn his delivery is perfect it's tomato soup
it's hot and creamy I can actually
feel it running down my throat
delicious here it comes blueberry pie and
cream it's the most marvelous blueberry pie
I've ever tasted holy too What's happen into
your face she's changing colors oh she's a
violet turning Violet Violet thingy yeah but
your face is turning blue oh no blue you're
turning Violet Violet it is that one yeah yeah
yeah what's happening you're blowing up like
a balloon like a blueberry you really done it
this time having you Wonka hey he said not to
eat it would you roll the young lady down to
the juicing room at once please what for for
squeezing got another puzzle
for you they don't look
confident
sure why can't you come on camera now you're
just having fun with her I got a blueberry
for a daughter where is fancy bread in the
heart or in the head shall We Roll on that
is a good question I love these like bars that
he drops no pun intended Wonka bars he keeps
dropping what's it making Mr Wonka fizzy lifting
drinks they fill you with gas and the gas is so
terrifically lifting that it lifts you right
off the ground like a balloon wa but I dareen
sell it yet it's still too powerful come on let
us try some please no absolutely not there'd be
children floating around all over the place
let's take a drink Charlie nobody's watching
yeah a small one won't hurt us whoops no
guys no guys not bad I can't understand
why we're in big trouble it's a very interesting
structure because it's so much about Charlie in
the beginning that didn't Charlie kind of takes a
back seat once we get here oh oh this is great oh
that's cool rather than them having a torturous
experience or having a joyous one watch this
Grandpa Wonderful Child wow what kind of
set is this I'm going to hi P I can't get
down pull him down we're in trouble
Charlie I can't stop it's pulling
me in it would still be fun to try this
drink out though please turn off the fan
oh they got to burp your way down burp burp if
you don't get down the ribbon I can't boy burp
again B up boy come on that's kind of gross they
can't be doing what they're doing but they are
they have to I haven't met the Oompa Loompa yet
who could do it these are the geese that lay the
golden egg just acknowledges it they have to he
just like turns right to them as if they haven't
left the room the geese are very temperamental
that's why we have the eggdicator the eggdicator
can tell the difference between a good egg and a
bad egg I love all the props they built if it's
a good egg it's shined up and shipped out all
over the world have they create some type of
like attraction where you can go visit these
things hey Daddy I want a Golden Goose Daddy
I'll get you Golden Goose as soon as we get home
no I want one of those one one of those I want one
now how much do you want for the Golden Goose
they're not for sale name me promise she can't
have one sure we didn't cut to WKA on that by
the way I want to Feast you EG before you came
to the factory I want a bean feast what a little
bruts and fruit NOS you're going to have all those
things when you get home no now I wonder what she
was really like on set she would what was she she
[Music]
Pleasant you're distracting the Oompa Loompas
from doing their job am especially perturbs me
[Music] oh my God what a devil woman I hope one
of the eggs falls on her head oh God she was a
bad egg where' she gone to the furnace it's so
matter of fact hold on Bara sweetheart daddy's
coming that a
horrible
there's a sadness in his performance
too blame I love how they get
these like music video subtitle
[Music] videos they are instilling
life lessons places please the dance
is about to begin everybody set is
this going to go fast Grandpa it's
sure Charlie has got more gas in it than
a politician I love that one stronger than
[Music]
[Applause] lion I'm sending you the cleaning Mr
W FR clean wow that is awesome what was that
we just went through is that Japanese no that's
Wonka spelled backwards there's dangerous stuff
inside Wonka Vision television uh it's w Vision
uh it's w ofion you photograph something then
the photograph is split up into millions of
tiny pieces and they go whizzing through the
air down to your TV set where they're all put
together again in the right order you should
open your m a little wider when you speak
I shall now send this chocolate bar from one end
of the room to the other action but does it cause
your the the chocolate to be radiated heads in
a million pieces whoa now watch the screen there
it is it's real taste it it's delicious it's
just gotten smaller that's all it's perfect
it's unbelievable it's a miracle it's a TV dinner
it's Wonka Vision it's Wonka Vision can you send
other things what about people get in there kid
but it might have some messy results look at me
I'm going to be the first person in the world to
be sent by television get away from that thing
stop don't come back I love how like disconcert
he actually is where are you he's up there in a
million pieces so not face he's going to be tiny
though mik why is he taking so long million pieces
take a long time to put together oh where are
they look at me everybody I'm the first person
in the world to be sent by television you're not
grasping the consequences of are you little boy
what you taking me I don't want to go in there be
quiet how will he grow well fortunately small boys
are extremely springy and elastic so I think
we'll put him in my special tattoo pulling
machine just swinging him around her you'll find
the boy in his mother's purse but be extremely
careful parting is such sweet sorrow it's kind of
a physically demanding movie on the actors isn't
it I'm [Music] listening I don't know I
amen too much [Music] work and that was the
end of them Mr Wonka what's going to happen
to the other kids I promise you they'll
be quite all right when they leave here
they'll be completely restored to their
normal terrible old selves and what do we
do now Mr Wonka straight up the stairs
you'll find the way I'm terribly busy
whole day wasted goodbye to you both whole day
wasted what happened did we do something wrong
a everything's in half here I just wanted to ask
about the chocolate when does he get it he doesn't
because he broke the rules under section 37b of
the contract signed by him I shall forfeit all
rights hearing and hearing contained etc etc
that's kind of a con you stole fizzy lifting
drinks you bumped into the ceiling which now
has to be washed so you get nothing wow he's
kind of cruel how can you do a thing like this
build up a little boy's hopes and then smash
all his dreams to Pieces you're an inhuman
monster I said good day oh that's so sad Mr
Wonka he won't give it over Charli
youve won forgive me for putting you
through this please forgive me come in Mr
Wilkinson Charlie meet Mr Wilkinson oh my
God I had to test you Charlie and you
passed it test I did not actually see
that coming this is the Great Glass
wonkavator it's an elevator it's a
wonkavator there it goes you mean
we're going up and out but this
roof is made of glass it'll
chatter in a thousand pieces
will be cut to Ribbons probably it's
actually kind of terrifying here it
comes whoa
with the Pure Imagination how did you like
the Chocolate Factory Charlie I think it's the
most wonderful place in the whole world I'm very
pleased to hear you say that because I'm giving
it to you you're giving Charlie the I can't go on
forever and I don't really want to try so who can
I trust to run the factory when I leave a that's
why I decided a long time ago that I I had to find
a child a very honest loving child to whom I can
tell all my most precious Candy Making Secrets
good thing you fixed them at random so the factory
is yours Charlie you can move in immediately what
happens to the rest the whole family I want you to
bring them all really everyone don't forget what
happened to the man who suddenly got everything he
always wanted what happened he lived happily ever
after what a great move movie
this movie is actually so good big
surprise oh my God what happened to Peter ostram
ostram Aloha reject Nation Greg here so many of
you guys know most of my days or a couple of
hours of filming and then most of the time it's
dedicated to like editing and a bunch of other
computer work often it can be like to like 10 to
12 hours a day and on top of that comfort food
is like my life's biggest Vice but as many of
you also know working out and getting healthier
has been a massive component for me this year in
particular so in this Whirlwind I have found
myself a perfect Ally for quick healthy meals
America's number one meal kit a meal kit that
I have subscribed to prior to ever agreeing
and working with them so yes this is a genuine
testimony and that is of course for hellofresh and
hellofresh is in just about ease about bringing
health and flavor to you your doorstep in this
holiday season forget about the stress of planning
meals for your healthc conscious friends friends
like me who will breede down the back of your neck
being like I can't eat that that's unhealthy so
with hell fresh I'm looking forward to hosting
holiday dinners that are not only delicious but
also cater to Healthy Lifestyles best part
the variety it is incredible I'm pescatarian
so they have these delicious meals just like Dijon
onion crunch salmon over lemon broccoli spaghetti
and for my more plant-based days to vegan Maple
carrot power bowls they aren't just meals they're
culinary Adventures I learned the word word
culinary during a long day the last thing I want
to do is spend a while cooking and that's where
helloof Fresh's 15minute meals are a lifesaver
they're quick nutritious and Oho tasty perfect for
my non-stop lifestyle so why not join me in making
this holiday season both health conscious and
delicious with hellofresh with over 45 recipes and
seasonal add-ons to choose from every week there's
always something new to try and here's something
to cheer about go to hellofresh.com reject free
and use code reject free for free breakfast for
life is that accurate that's sounds way too good
to be true there's no way that can be true go to
hellofresh.com reex free and use code reject
free for free breakfast for Life One breakfast
item per box as long as your subscription
is active tag your hellofresh creations with
hashtag hellofresh pic and at hellofresh and
let's cook up some fun and healthiness reject
Nation remember it's America's number one meal kit
Okie doie ladies and gentlemen uh boys and girls
ah I quite loved this movie prior to starting it
I was a bit apprehensive you see when I was like
really really young don't ask me what scene I just
remember having a thought when I was a kid going
oh wait no okay let me start this again all righty
guys well if you're listening to this on Apple
or Spotify please rate that video we got a real
rejects podcast going for those watching us here
on YouTube I'm trying to I'm trying to conduct
this for two different audiences one who just
hear and one who can see any who uh just watched
wiie Wonka in the Chocolate Factory first time
ever and a little bit of background here probably
should have given this on the said on the patreon
one but I should give it on the YouTube one so
I did I did see the Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory movie the one that Tim Burton did when it
first came out in the theaters I barely remember
it I mean that with the utmost sincerity barely
remember what happens in that film uh I remembered
like basically about that Charlie eventually gets
to the chra Factory and then Johnny de's a little
creepy um but I honestly kind of part of my brain
was was racking St going he he gets does he get
the chocolate fact I was kept like asking myself
that was like I think he gets the chocolate B but
I don't remember if he does and yeah it's like
I I definitely didn't remember it well enough to
like be making comparisons or or have an idea of
like oh here's what the structure the movie is I
don't even remember if this slugworth or whatever
the hell this guy's name is is in the Johnny Depp
one or not like so that was like the the most
Association I have with it and um when I was
a kid I I I saw maybe like 30 seconds of this on
TV and I must have been like really really young
and I went this looks like an old movie I don't
want to watch it and I just never did but here I
am now and I I loved it I really did love it it
it it is such a fascinating experience because
while you know it while it is from an older era
I do find the way this movie is executed to feel
rather Timeless like I I wasn't distracted by
the period in which it was captured if anything
like it actually helps amplify the experience and
the magic behind it of making this feel even more
Fantastical by the era itself set and so I don't
know like if I guess my question that I'm asking
is the year in which the I don't know if this
movie makes it explicitly clear when it takes
place like what year it does because this is all
a fictional world of of this guy with this amazing
Chocolate Factory and everyone just wants a piece
of that candy uh I I don't know what year it takes
place in in the movie itself but is it supposed to
take place for whatever year this movie came out
in the 70s is it supposed to take place then does
this take place in the 70s what I'm asking I don't
know you guys let me know below uh but I actually
feel like the it encapsulates it more in a way
that does have it feel a lot more magical due to
that fact uh and I I love the production design
of everything it's everything is so vibrant it
pops uh the entire film just had this sort of uh
Whimsical Elegance about it it's it's structured
in a in kind of an odd way if there was one bit
of criticism that I might it's strange because the
first like 40 minutes you don't go to wiie Wonka
you're like kind of building him up right and I
really love that part of the the movie a lot like
my heart was so in it when it came to everyone
looking for the golden tickets and kind of hopping
around the world and seeing who's who and and how
everyone responds to this and it was really funny
it seemed like that this play on society that I
was really enjoying and and Charlie who is the
guy who plays Charlie my God I gotta look him up
I I just got to look him up and I'm gonna kill the
dead air while I'm here uh 1971 is when this came
out because yeah I I don't know if this this kid
is still alive uh he's not a kid anymore that's
for sure is he alive Peter ostram did he only
do one movie is that it what happened to him what
happened to this guy I don't even see like Modern
Day photos of him okay well he was in something
called remembering Jee Wilder in 2023 so I imagine
he's still around and kicking it a little bit
but anyway um I thought he was excellent uh he
he really captured this sort of like innocence
this this Purity that felt just so multi-layer
like yeah he's got this like optimism this
hopefulness and um this uh exudes empathy and all
all basically all the qualities that Willie Wonka
lists about him you know with the the honesty and
the integrity and and at the same time he's got
this like resilience and perseverance about his
attitude that I that that I I love so much because
whenever an obstacle was thr his way he would try
to find a way to be optimistic he never like got
too down in the gutters about anything and I I
feel like just the way he was played was perfect
I really cared about him and it you could feel
kind of that the the way how true optimism ought
to be executed is you got to have that feeling of
H you're you're constantly up against the wall of
feeling defeated and that's why you have to have
optimism for example like if if you were to have
courage you must have an element of fear otherwise
what's the point of Courage because courage has
to be the thing that's counteracting against fear
right and and I really think he he embodied that
so well and like the relationship with his grandpa
that I thought well Grandpa Joe is the character's
name uh again uh you know even though he is an
elderly man he I thought he had such a a youthful
Spirit about him as well and for him to be sort
of this uh Storyteller and mentor to Charlie was
great like I just really love the characters and
I wasn't expecting that because they had such a
curiosity and enthusiasm about them that and so
much support and love as well so all that like
lay it on to it with really catchy Tunes really
catchy songs and and very appealing visuals and
the way the movie is also edited it mov like the
first 40 minutes kind of felt like it was edited
sort of like a Martin scorsi movie which which was
the last thing I expected to say when going into
Wily Wonka film but it did remind me a bit of like
a scorsi fast-paced editing style of something
that he would have made in in the 70s but you
know was a lot more PG friendly and less gangster
Catholic driven and so I really I really loved it
cuz there was such a youthful Spirit about it
uh from beginning to end and then when you get
to like Willie Wonka the movie then adapts you
know what it does it's it's actually now that I'm
thinking about like with the words I was about to
say it sly made me appreciate it because the first
40 minutes while you do cut around other people
it's still primarily your are watching it from
Charlie's perspective and and then when you get
to Wily Wonka now you are the audience observing
like you are one of the golden ticket winners
who are on this journey with with Willie Wonka
and and you're just trying to figure out who this
guy is because like Gan Wilder nailed it you know
um I I remember like not mind in the the Charlie
and the CH Factory Johnny Depp one uh but clearly
I've never cared to revisit it I don't didn't
leave an impression on me when I was younger
I definitely didn't hate it I remember thinking
it was creepier um but I but what what they did
here with Gene Wilder and I you know and just
kind of having a bit of an understanding of how
Gene Wilder operates I imagine he was very much
creatively involved more than we might expect uh
yeah he's very eccentric very whim musical I think
he does capture that creative Innovative side of
wily Wonka but yet there's that mystery the the
the secrecy behind him that it is very captivating
and same time he's got the the dark humor and
he's got this sarcasm and yet there's still a
um a depth behind those eyes like I believe that
whole speech at the end that that was the entire
motive even if even if there was a bit of a ploy
there in order to provoke Charlie into giving up
they slug nugget they I don't remember what this
was called the candy thing to to test him uh I you
still believe this this um this sadness and this
melan there's a bit of like a Melancholy and a bit
of vulnerability to him I thought it's actually a
really multi-layered performance even though it's
not one where you're like ah here's how he starts
and here's this character Arc or something like
that that's like explicitly clear and while a big
part of it is to keep you at a distance and make
him mysterious and a bit like mischievous and do I
really trust this guy he seems a little bit scary
but I also kind of love him I believed every I I
felt like the unpredictability and the uh overall
ambiguity of right that's the right choice of
words the the unpredictability ambiguity of of
this character genan Wilder just embodied it so
well my initial impression and I made a comment
about it while I was doing the reaction though
is that I did kind of feel like we lost sight
while we do become the audience kind of observing
willly Wonka and you were hopping back and forth
between how Willie Wonka is observing and stuff
and and that is like the overall game I did find
myself like losing a sense of that connection
with Charlie which was the the thing that the
movie hooked me in when the first 40 minutes
is uh we are living vicariously through Charlie
he is the character who we are latched on to and
then through a lot of the journey throughout the
Chocolate Factory you're not really in Charlie's
perspective and you don't really cut to him a lot
and I I did miss I did I did find myself craving
that the last thing I expected to to say was I I
just wanted to spend more time with Charlie while
we're in the Chocolate Factory and I I do think
that is one of the the like while I while I I have
two sides two feelings about it and it's possible
to have two feelings and I got two feelings about
it one is I love being in the audience perspective
and just watching Willie Wonka do I keep want
to call Willy Wonka Charlie uh watching Willie
Wonka do his thing and then the other side is
oh but I I'm the character journey of being
in Charlie's shoes and getting a little bit more
nuggets of of of like maybe Willie Wonka observing
Charlie and seeing how it contrasts against the
choices that the other kids do I did find myself
missing some of that but by the time you get
to the finale and and I still really enjoyed
the journey throughout the Chocolate Factory I
did I like it's psychedelic it's weird as hell
um but I I loved it I I did love it and then when
you do get to the the final moments it is it is
extremely touching and it it does feel cathartic
you know and and earned and like I could see how
there are some things that maybe the story might
not have aged as strong as people might I don't
know I don't really give a [__] like the one
the one thing that come comes to mind is seems
a little bit moralistic you know he kind of
seems judgmental of people but whatever this
is a [__] movie from the 70s and it's a family
film and they're keeping it simple they're keeping
it simple and and I really liked it but but even
if you do have that feeling I think there's a lot
of great morality lessons there's a lot of like
good cautionary tale stuff about um things against
the deadly sins you know the greed gluttony uh
laziness and and uh I I feel like there is uh
like commentary on wealth disparity and and also
the appreciation of you know just like family and
connection and the the simple the simple things
of life you know but also uh the encouragement on
imagination you know like the songs really speak
a lot of volumes to that and and and and the value
of of being a of maintaining integrity and and um
I I I also imagine that there's probably some um
I don't imagine I think it's there in the movie
there there seems to be like commentary too on
on parenting and and the importance of how you
raise a kid and how a lot of this is instilled
in the value of like because you got the grandpa
like the dad's not around for Charlie but you got
Grandpa and Charlie and then here you're watching
the relationship between like either a father and
a a child or a mother and a child and you're
watching how these children developed and how
the parents kind of spoil them and there seems to
be a lot of uh emphasis on parenting as well and
that how important that is to the development of
a child h i I really loved that aspect of it and
just um overall yeah it's great it's great film
with the enigmatic qualities of wily Wonka but
there's just this Spirit of innovation throughout
and while there's like some um caution Ary tale
elements to it with wonderful music and great
performances solid Direction all around and
just a lot of heart it just has a lot of heart I
thought this was a really solid film and I could
see why it stands a test of time and I don't even
I don't have no Nostalgia for this and I I found
myself very much moved and I'm very surprised by
just how much I ended up loving it I thought I'd
be more here going you know I really appreciated
it and I could see why people like it let me tell
you why I think people really like it uh I did
not actually expect to walk out of this movie
going wow I really did love it um and and I loved
it before we even got to Wily Wonka and that to me
is a testament to this movie strength but guys
uh how do you feel about Willie Wonka on the
Chocolate Factory do you like the Johnny Depp one
and are you excited for the Timothy sham one what
is your favorite moment from here uh if there's
something I did not talk about that you wish
talked about well you can talk about it in the
comments below thank you again and uh I'll catch
you all soon thank you guys so much for being
here rejack night John pick a name any name oh how
about Maria Hammond Maria Hammond you know what
you're getting for Christmas this year oo you're
going to get you know I thought of a really dirty
joke and then I thought you you know as as close
as we've gotten I still am like I feel like I'm
one joke away from completely ruining all Goodwill
we have established with each other Maria so now
I'm not as conf should I just go for it I think
it's a super light dirty Joe it's like not even
that dirty but I was like you know we're always
like ah you're like the mother at our patreon
you like a son and I was like that was be kind
of weird if I made a dirty joke well I I mean
it depends on if the joke is about that context
I guess all right okay there's a way to make both
of this work all right Maria you're going to get a
Polaroid of me naked this year and then you're GNA
go Greg you're like a son to me should sending me
these photos why would you paint our relationship
this way and I think if there's one thing you love
more than receiving gifts is giving gifts and
you will give me the gift a less in behavior of
knowing when I'm crossing the line hey and you
got to cross the line to find it based off of
the scrutinization you dish my way for being um a
callous with my behavior yes keeping you honest so
I appreciate you Maria always keeping me in check
my sweet sweet hot mom you greggy's mom has got it
going on this Christmas yeah and I'm gonna get
you a ham oh and I'll get you some almonds and
then you can crust the ham it can be ham Hamond
where' you get the Almond from uh I thought the
first half of Hammond is ham and the second half
is Mund and the second half of almond is also Mund
so I was like I'm getting her a Polaroid of me
naked and you're getting her an almond you said
you're getting her a ham I can I can I'll paint a
self portra myself and to her in addition to the
AL sorry about the let down there Mar okay no it's
up to you to decide it okay we love you dear Merry
Christmas I hope you have a good one with your
family this year you deserve it you [Music] do